in the past five years Bitcoin is up 113
percent gold is 53 percent S P 500 is
52. Dow Jones is 35. if you go back to
uh the year 2000 you know I think is not
necessarily relevant for you know people
my age then you would have gained way
more buying gold than anything else
and then uh in the past five years the S
P 500 and gold are comparable you know
we all look at that we think about
Investments how do we protect our wealth
and that is important because that's how
do I live but uh ultimately if you look
at all those different Investments that
we have that we can do uh
I actually the only thing that's going
to be important to us is if we have our
freedom because because what did
Roosevelt do within one announcement a
month after he was in office he took all
the gold in by force it confiscated the
gold there was gold confiscation in the
United States many people don't even
know about it nobody owned nobody was in
the United States was a lot of on gold
from 1933 up till
1975 and that was that was when I was
trying to get gold legalized you know
that's a long time so that's uh that's
pretty amazing but I think one of the
most important metrics to look at is the
purchasing power of the dollar and when
you look at that and what it used to buy
you and now what it buys you I mean
there's horrible tragic stories of
individuals burying their money or
putting it underneath their couch and
I'm like you people don't understand one
of the biggest taxes out there is
inflation it's a hidden tax many people
don't know about it but the value of
your dollar of what you worked hard for
or is slowly being eviscerated by the
government and their irresponsible
Financial policies there was a story
where a young couple
uh open up the floorboards in their
attic and found a box that their
grandfather or that this guy's
grandfather had had hidden away with
fifty thousand dollars in it and boy
paper money and boy were they so excited
to find fifty thousand dollars and
they're like wow little do they realize
that it's basically a million dollars if
he had properly invested it because the
US dollar is not sound exactly and and
just seeing this happening because now I
think it's it's kind of quickening now
when you go to the grocery store you see
it more and more kind of evident and
more and more in your face not just what
egg prices but that has to deal with a
lot of other circumstances and
situations but overall when you're at
the grocery store when you pay for
everything it's a lot more than it was
before and that's not an accident we
just went to the grocery store and as we
are checking out the it was 200 bucks
for like one half bag of it was like
cheese tea some meat and some some
hummus and then we were like how is this
two hundred dollars what is it well it
was like 8 dollars for a little thing of
hummus it was it was eight dollars for a
pack of cheese and we were like yeah we
filled up a bag with you know some deli
meats some cheese some dips and some
drinks and they're like eight to ten
bucks each and it doesn't take a genius
to see all of this because during covid
they were like we're gonna give you guys
a two thousand dollar check but we're
gonna give you billion dollars more to
all the private entities and
corporations that were in business with
and and having that much of money just
printed out of thin air those two
thousand dollars were nothing compared
to the secret corporate and banking
bailouts that were given out to some of
the biggest institutions in the world
their losses were were were private
we're we're public we're publicized that
their profits were privatized this is a
this is a system that we're we're
dealing with right now that isn't
capitalistic this is socialism for the
super rich everyone else screw yourself
and this is a big notion that I think a
lot of leftists need to understand here
this is not capitalism this is this is
direct elitism socialism for the super
rich that are able to get away and do
whatever really want while everyone else
is being screwed over you know the words
that they use makes a big difference too
because even here and I'll do it quite
frequently but I try not to ever refer
to inflation as a CPI and prices going
up and mises I used to say well that's
just semantics just did you know qualify
it or something but Mason said no that's
on purpose because if the price of such
and such went up that means prophets
they made too many profits oh Labor's
going up too fast labor unions did that
at the same time if if we concentrate on
the inflation it's back to the money if
you dilute the money supply by printing
money that that is the culprit that's
the inflation so I try never to talk
about the cpio oh it showed a lot of
inflation last year but this is this is
a trick many leftists use I see them say
something like the economy is not doing
poorly these corporations brought in
record profits and it's like yes
inflation is at 15 percent so if a
corporation brings in say 10 billion
more dollars and they they typically
bring in 100 million dollars it is just
Rising with inflation that is to say the
buying power of what they brought in is
the same but the monetary number is
bigger therefore it's the corporation's
fault for making record profits and
that's the trick they use to say C
capitalism is the problem these
corporations are making record profits
while you're suffering no the reason you
can't buy milk bread and eggs is because
it's six bucks for a carton of eggs
right now and so that means those
corporations their costs have gone up
the same and so their profit percentage
is the same but the number is bigger
because of inflation yeah yeah talking
percentages and not in in finite amounts
when you want to talk about profits
that's a good point those are the tricks
they use to be like oh how did they make
50 billion this year you know Ron you
mentioned um units of account and how
our money is lost a form of account and
that gold was our used to be the way you
would account for money and then you
said something about social account a
unit of account for social social units
of account what did you mean by that
well I think you have to have a value uh
the nihilists have a value truth doesn't
exist the other one is there is truth
out there and uh and it it might not be
you might not have the same definition
but it principle all the way back to
before Hammurabi wrote his code they had
an idea and the code uh would would
Define
even back then when it was such a
primitive era they said you should kill
people you shouldn't steal from people
and that's a higher law it's a higher
law that was known to all civilizations
and uh I think that you have to have
have that but it's a Truth Versus
nihilism is a good way to do it but I
think it's also a higher law which has
been uh known about and accepted on uh
you know from the beginning of time from
time of Adam and Eve it implies right
and wrong good and bad and if you had
that you have no unit of account on
social order so is this like um social
credit score kind of like this is it
like a an aberration of of what we're
supposed to think is truth like truth is
what they tell you it is as opposed to
truth is don't kill people I guess it
could be but the social credit thing
that's I mean I don't want to get near
that one I agree and I wonder if losing
touch with our unit of account from the
Bible I was never really raised in that
way religiously but I think that there's
value to it like that if we lose touch
with that then another form of account
will come in the way you account to the
state something like that I think the
woke left have no moral framework it's
just power and then the traditional
judeo-christian values of the United
States is a moral framework so I think
that's a big dividing point in the
culture War those who and I said this
before uh Bill Maher is a great example
of this he says he's an atheist he
doesn't believe in God but he holds all
of these Christian values such as the
right uh presumption of innocence which
is rooted in the story of Sodom Gomorrah
as the principal example I tend to use
but here's a guy who was raised in a
society that held these values to be
true he then says but I don't believe
about him I don't believe anything about
a man in the sky or a resurrection or
anything and that's those stories are
totally separate from the moral values
of presumption of innocence for example
and so he grows up he lives a life and
he says I don't believe those stories
but I'm going to tell you we have to
hold these values true
when people then grew up completely
outside of that religion that never even
hearing the stories or any of those
values they don't recognize presumption
of innocence what do they recognize the
only thing that matters is how powerful
you are and what you can take
very well I've got a burning question I
wanted to ask you at the beginning of
the show Ron and I'll ask you now if you
had the internet in 1976 before you ran
for Congress would you have started a
YouTube channel instead
I had trouble starting in 1982 or 1992.
no I'm not it I think about it in theory
and in principle and usage and the
practicality on how you get the
information out and my job I spend most
of my time is trying to understand
things that's why I was fascinated with
just the fundamentals of Economic Policy
if it was the Leonard Reed in the
foundation for economic education to me
this was exciting and I used to Kid
myself I said boy I'm sure glad I found
these people that agree with me and of
course it was the other way around
because it's it's been there a long time
so I I think that uh you know people
people you know can't find a thing but
that to me was the most interesting
thing is to say search I think once you
discover that you're not going to know
you know we might just say we all agree
on the general principles that sounds
good having truth and non-aggression
principle but each one of us who might
apply it a little bit differently
because the one thing the conservatives
can't do is leap over this and accept
you know somebody else's personal
behavior and then they want to regulate
that that means they've leaped over uh
too far and that means they have to use
Force to do that that's why the idea of
aggression has to be very very definite
you said something at the very beginning
of the show about there being no honest
people in Washington DC or something
that affects and I wanted to say this
right away but I can think of at least
one I can think of more than one but to
be fair at least one and that's Rand
Paul who uh your son obviously and then
you also mentioned you know had kids in
college and I think that Rand is one of
the only politicians that I think is
doing a good job that actually is doing
right I think they're all far from
perfect but everyone's human and then
there's people like Thomas Matthew I
think is doing a tremendous amount she's
very good I'm wondering what your
thoughts are on uh on the current state
of Congress and obviously I assume you
think your son's doing a good job but
I'm curious to hear your thoughts well
once again I don't get into the detail
of that be I've I've over the years
don't even like using their names well I
thought we had a little rally after they
did allow me and uh in in the uh at the
time of the election they they didn't
permit me to speak at the convention and
uh I um so we had our own rally I think
that was where were we in Florida I was
there it was a great event well anyway
it was and uh I think I spoke on average
about an hour or so and I did in the
crowd with was just great and I never
said I never say oh I gave a great
speech I say the crowd makes your speech
you know made all the difference and so
I uh I was uh you know just really
amazed you know at the reception that we
got there so it was huge it was a
stadium there was multiple stadiums uh
in Florida that that particular year as
well and there was multiple shows and
multiple people being like this is a
representation of the people that's not
being represented by the corporate media
that's not being represented by the
political class and there was so much
discontent because finally we had a
voice that was being heard but it was
being censored by the media I was being
downranked everywhere uh which was crazy
well when I finished that speech
somebody came up to me it might have
been a friendly reporter or somebody
that wasn't coming matter of fact it
maybe was a criticism I didn't know it
he he personally came up he says you
know you talk for over an hour he says
and who who were my opponents and see
that was uh was was Trump was no I don't
think that was Trump I think that was
Romney Romney had it yeah Gingrich no
who was the Democrat
um that was uh 2008 Obama and Hillary
and the guy came up and he says you
talked for an hour he says you never
mentioned either their names
you're supposed to go after your
opponents so I didn't mention the
Republic order the Democrat so I I put
that down on the list well I think it's
a distraction and I I never enjoyed it
even though I have to admit that I've
been getting pretty sloppy and Daniel
has to put up with it because
there's one person that does upset me
and it happens to be a woman and that
doesn't mean I don't like women I mean
that was Nancy Pelosi
I think she's a nihilist oh yeah a
narcissist power hungry if I could just
ask you throughout all of your years
surrounding by all all of these horrible
people in Congress do you attribute what
they're doing because of malice or
ignorance why do you think they were
doing what they were doing why do you
think they're such a cause for bad let
me just simplify that Luke are they
stupid or are they evil yes sir that's
yeah that's better yes yes
I I think that the the problem that I
look at is intellectual and philosophic
I we we started a conversation with
talking about uh you know 1913 and I
said even a little earlier uh I think
people are influenced by that type of
thing and the control of the scenario
the control the propaganda uh is the
real is the real problem now the
individuals they're sloppy they're not
well informed uh you know I had people
come up some liberal Democrats when I
first went there in the 70s they'd come
up and they say I can't figure out what
you're doing why are you voting with
this guy over here and I just sort of
laugh because I kind of charge out of it
but uh no there's and I I think there's
there that's where we're making progress
I think people are that's why I love to
see young people talking about these
issues I think most of people don't know
how much influence they have because I
certainly don't believe some of the
things people tell me about oh you do
this but if people all you have to do is
to have a small small group if you have
10 people
you know and you're not you're even
denied the information you'll never know
well how many people watch your show we
probably got about 50 000 or more right
now but but you don't know what that 50
000 might do in the next 10 years well
one thing that's the way things change
ideas and I'll say this to you and one
thing I've only start realized you know
maybe like a year ago is people tell us
when they're watching they're actually
watching with three or four other people
so it says one but it's actually a
family or it's a group of friends who
are hanging out but I'll say this to you
uh uh Dr Paul and Congressman uh I don't
I don't I don't know if I would be here
right now if you were not doing what you
were doing you know throughout your
entire career the things that I started
learning online the speeches that I saw
from you had had a tremendous influence
and I think Luke obviously the same
thing he's at your rallies so you may
get started with this one idea and as
you mentioned you tell the 10 people
those 10 people tell 10 more those 10
people tell 10 more and before you know
it 30 years goes by and you're sitting
on some dude's podcast who's like
remember that one thing you said about
the wrong prescription for war and
you're like oh did I did I say that like
yeah I had a huge impact on my view of a
lot of the stuff too so I think you know
there's probably a lot of people out
there right now who hear even this show
and we don't even realize okay I always
and more private conversations when we
get into these talks like this I always
want to know more about you know where
you were why you changed what happens
and I don't do it for you to say nice
things about me but what what was it
that caught your attention uh mine is a
little more a bit more more complex I
narrowed down the monetary issue but do
you remember
what it was that well it got your
attention I voted for Obama in 2008. I
had seen a lot of things on the internet
I had a lot of friends I had I had heard
about you I had seen the revolution
stickers and things like that
um I think that was around that time
it's it's you know it's been a long time
but I remember uh I remember Barack
Obama was supposedly going to be the
anti-war guy that the bush the bush air
was completely wrong people are Marching
through the street saying he was Hitler
and then I'm this young kid and I'm
listening to punk rock music war is bad
war is wrong blah blah blah and I agree
I'm like I don't understand why why we
keep hearing these stories about
civilians being killed I don't
understand and I research it and I learn
about it and I to understand the history
and I read about you know Desert Storm
and things like that I was a lot younger
I read about the Cold War and then I say
I don't trust the government
Barack Obama is supposedly going to be
hope and change and I'm young and naive
and people tell me you better understand
he's an Insurgent candidate he's not
supposed to be there it's supposed to be
Hillary she's she's the she's the
establishment vote for Obama and I'm
like wow is this really really the
change and you know one of the first
things Obama does when he gets into
office is he bombs a village of women
and children with a drone strike or I
think it might have been an airstrike or
something like that under the guise of
terrorist hunting and I was like okay
well that's weird but but maybe maybe
that was from the old Administration
like I'm gonna give him a chance and
then he surged our troops in Afghanistan
and then I just got really jaded and
angry and was just like so they lied to
me so that's the whole time sounds to me
like the war issue was a big issue for
you yeah absolutely and of course then
everything you had been saying about the
war was I started asking myself why is
it that it's this Republican candidate
who was preaching against War who's
still preaching against War who is his
now I can see as the track record of
actually caring about these issues and
then I started to see them hypocrisy in
these other liberal and Democrat voters
who told me they opposed the war but the
moment Barack Obama got elected they
stopped caring and I was like you lied
to me that put a chip on my shoulder and
I got deeply offended and distrustful of
these people and not to mention I never
liked Republicans as it was so what I
ended up seeing was more of
I I've never considered myself like a
right-leaning libertarian or a
conservative I remember seeing you give
certain speeches where I was like well I
don't agree with that but the one thing
I always said and I think the mises
caucus actually quoted me and they made
a little graphic was I thought to myself
you know this guy Ron Paul is saying you
know here's what I believe but you know
what I think the government should leave
you all alone and I thought to myself
well okay I can vote for that he can
believe whatever he wants as long as he
leaves me alone right and so that that
was a big factor and you know I would
consider myself kind of like a Centrist
libertarian type more you know like more
freedom less less government a little
bit of government I'm not an anarchist
or anything like that but I think I I
think the the Obama being a liar thing
and it was kind of like they spat on me
they they lied to me they insulted me
and I just don't trust them and I see
you consistent I see uh and I was I was
a huge Bernie Sanders supporter in 2015
and 16 for a similar reason he was more
what I thought of as the left-wing
version of you anti-war Pro worker all
these things sure enough that was was
another lie he ends up just catering
straight to the establishment the moment
they tell him to makes a million bucks
selling a book and then says you can be
a millionaire if you write a book too
and I'm like was all of that a lie too I
don't look I got a message I just don't
like any of these politicians but you
know you seem to have retired with Grace
and dignity and remain consistent on all
your positions then you your son is in
there uh doing great work as well and
I'm like the these these These are the
only few politicians I actually think
have ever ever meant it to be honest but
did they ever try to buy you off did
they ever try to silence you or stop you
no they always insulted me they never
came to see me you think that if you no
the lobbyists didn't come did they come
to our office one time and you kicked
them out
I did you listened to him first you
listen to him first if you become
president in OA 2008 do you think that
they would have been like here's who
you're gonna bomb next and if you were
like no that they would have jfk'd you
uh well that's hard to say but uh
if if you did more than that if you
really changed things uh there'd be a
revolution uh that
for some reason whether they kill you or
what but anybody that supported it it
would be done it's not going to happen
that's why that's why he we have to
expect the collapse to come in a
different way nobody's gonna we can't
get enough people Congress to pass past
the right law to really change things
it's good that we have there and we have
a few more now than we did before you
know with the recent election but it's
uh it would be catastrophic if you
really change it if you you can't close
down the fed the FED has to close
themselves down yeah you mentioned
auditing the FED at the time it was a
2009 or 10 or 11 or something you're
talking about auditing the fed and I
kept thinking no repeal the Federal
Reserve Act of 1913 repeal but now what
you're saying is that would undercut
pull the rug yeah well I want to repeal
it I've had bills into repeal and it's
just that uh I had I had a lot of
Democrats sign on to auditing the fed
and all the Republicans but they
wouldn't have I wouldn't have gotten
five votes to to abolish the Fed
there's a famous thing it was a practice
it became paragmatic but it was also to
me educational because I was I was
surprised we did that why why why won't
they vote for auditing
the FED I I what's what's their are
lobbyists coming at them are their lives
threatened uh well because there's that
money is being distributed secretly the
it's it's a really a big privilege I
think that uh where was it I read I
think it was 31 trillion dollars they
passed out over covet but it's off the
books I mean they don't they don't go
through Congress you know to appropriate
this money it is and they don't want
that to be revealed that's why I said
the thing they want to protect the most
are the international transactions
that's where they wheel and deal and
keep the bank going about International
settlements that's probably do a lot of
the wheeling and dealing and the
bailouts are secret a lot of the money
is being moved around no one even knows
exactly where it's going who is this
going to I confronted Ben Bernanke about
this issue the guy tried to steal my
microphone from me because I was like
where's the money going to how much
money are you giving people and this was
all the way back in 2011. but but the
good news is the market is more powerful
than the politicians and that is why
Brenton Woods broke down that's why
Henry Haslett was right all through the
60s were right and the people said it
won't work it won't work and finally it
didn't work and that's why the same
people are saying the dollar is going to
get much much weaker and they it will
lose its Reserve stand it's a it's a
reserve Reserve country uh credentials
what do you think is like a cogent move
forward to try and bring it into a slow
Landing soft Landing as soft as we can
you can't do that
but because the time has passed the best
example to know what we could have done
and should have done is 1921 because it
was a very serious depression it's 21
and I I guess whoever was still in but
the keynesianism hadn't taken over they
just say you didn't bail people out you
know it's bad debt liquidate the debt
and get it over with so they did nothing
and after a little over a year the GDP I
think went down like 15 percent and then
everybody you know had to go back to
scratch and ever after that everything
was growth you know the markets were
growing again and you could have done
that and you could do it now but
politically it wouldn't be acceptable so
start businesses it's in the in the
private sector what if we were going to
do it like a soft Landing or something
it would be like by creating
productivity but not waiting for the
politicians well that's why the market
is important I think that you you could
you know if you took all of the dumb
economic things that buying has done
especially in energy blowing up
pipelines you know doing all that
nonsense and more regulation if you
remove that that would be helpful that
would increase productivity and lower
prices but uh but the the debt is too
big that is going to haunt us and people
will worry rightfully so that that this
the debt will be liquidated uh and uh
they are going to default but the
default counts because the debt is
shrinking right now because of the money
is worth so little and they they can't
quit doing that you know they even talk
about you know raising interest rates
right now each day if they go if they
say one word to hint that well interest
rates are going to go up a little bit
you know the markets could add a
trillion dollars it's just crazy all
right is this Beyond repair thanks for
watching this clip from the 10 cast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time